AND LOUIE HERE
DRAISAITL.
THE SAVE MADE ON DERICK
BRASSARD
SHOT BY EDLER TIPPED HOME!
AND JUST LIKE THAT L.A.'s ON
THE BOARD.
I BELIEVE KALIYEV GETS A
LITTLE PIECE OF THAT OT, SAVE.
QUICK.
REBOUND AND THAT'S TOSSED
OUT OF THE BLUE PAINT BY
PULJUJARVI.
I WAS ON THE TOMMY BOY PLAN
WHEN IT CAME
PULJUJARVI WHO WAS JUST
OUTSTANDING IN THAT GAME
YOUR CAREER, SOME OF THE
WORST PAIN YOU HAD WAS WHEN
YOU GOALS.
AND THAT WAS A HIT IF I'M
NOT MISTAKEN ON
SORRY THAT'S STECHER 51, NOT
ONE ACROSS, RIGHT THERE.
>> Jack: OHED.
THEY HAVE TO BE REDY.
GREAT ONES ALWAYS DO.
GETS HIS HEAD UP.
LITTLE DELAY.
MAKES THIS PARI.
HELD IN BY SEASON.
>>
GAME AGAIN.
AS THIS GOES AROUND, COMES
OFF THE CAROM AS AN
E PULJUJARVIE
BOARDS FOR CONNOR McDAVID.
CHANGE OF SPEED.
OFF KOPITAR. UP SPACE IN
FRONT OF THE NET.
NO CHANCE FOR JONATHAN
QUICK.
IT DOES GO OFF THE BODY O ICE
CLEAR.
DURZI.
KNOCKED IT AWAY THE PUCK I
DIDN'T THINK.
THAT WAS THE PROROR 50 AT LEASTE
G
DARNELL NURSE ALONGSIDE,
RATHER, DARNE
1:20 GONE BY IN O.T.
LOS RELOAD 70
SECOND TO PLAY AND A
YOU'VE GOT JOR THE MIDDLE!
43 FOR 116 IN HIS